hey everyone welcome to this interesting
video on business analyst training by
simply learn
in this session we will deep dive into
the life of a business analyst
let's look at the agenda for today
we'll start off with the importance of
business analyst in an organization
then we'll move on to understanding who
exactly a business analyst is
the responsibilities and skills
after which we look at the various
business analysis knowledge areas and
learn about agile scrum methodologies we
will conclude this session with an
interesting hands-on demo on business
analytics with excel so without any
further ado let's get started with this
business analyst training
we will understand the importance of
business analyst with a sort and
interesting story
so meet rob he runs a cafe in a small
town far away his cafe is one of the
oldest and most popular eateries in town
rob's cafe was hugely popular amongst
customers and it was doing very well
until the onset of the deadly
coronavirus
due to covet 19 like other eateries rob
was forced to shut down his cafe too
this took a heavy toll on his business
and subsequently he lost his customers
none of his customers visited his cafe
and this resulted in a huge loss for him
he knew he couldn't afford to close his
business forever as it would take time
for coronavirus to be eradicated
but he was lost this situation was new
to him and he didn't know how to reopen
his business amidst this pandemic
after a lot of brainstorming he
recollected reading about business
analysts he remembered that business
analysts are professionals who enable a
change in an organization he felt like a
business analyst could help him sort out
his current business problems hence
without wasting any time he set out to
hire a business analyst
he hired ted the business analyst to
help him with his ongoing business
problems rob entrusted ted with
reopening the business
the first step ted took was to have a
discussion with rob and understand the
business problems and the objectives
that is ideally the first step a
business analyst would take
on discussion with rob ted learned that
the business objective was to reopen the
business and get at least 80 percent of
the customer base back in addition to
that rob also wanted ted to look for
sustainable ways to reopen and continue
the business in the long run amidst the
pandemic
ted studied the case and he came up with
a few suggestions that he thought was
fit for rob's business
his first suggestion was to develop an
exclusive home delivery app for rob's
cafe
this way ted knew that business will
improve as customers prefer home
delivery in the current scenario
next ted suggested that rob has work
from home meal boxes added to his menu
many professionals are working from home
currently and having work from home meal
boxes would be a good pick for such
professionals in the middle of a busy
day
ted's third suggestion was to bring down
the selling cost by providing discount
coupons that can be utilized by
customers
having a discount will enable more
customers to order from rob's cafe of
course it was not possible to get the
customer base back without any short of
price cuts in the current situation
finally ted suggested the drop staff
would facilitate home delivery orders
this way he didn't have to lay off his
staff and at the same time get the home
delivery running so these were a few
suggestions given by ted yes depending
on the situation business analysts can
take up different approaches
so after the suggestions were accepted
by rob for the app ted began to make
sure that the development went well by
collaborating with the iit team
that became the intermediary between the
it team and rob he provided suggestions
to the team checked the app through user
interface testing and made sure that the
requirements met well
the same applied to the other business
requirements and changes as well ted
held regular meetings to gaze the
progress and also kept rob in the loop
and updated him with the status of the
project
attending regular catch-ups helped rob
gain an insight into the progress and
give his feedback from time to time
ted made sure that the entire case was
well documented by doing so he could
always refer to the documents in the
future with similar cases as well
ted
made presentations that showed rob the
business growth after implementing the
changes and ted always supported his
presentations with data
rob was very impressed with ted's
business approach
such an approach not only helped rob
reopen his business amidst the cove at
19 but also helped him get 80 of his
customer base back ted successfully
brought about a positive change in rob's
business which was highly beneficial
so that is how ted the business analyst
helped rob make a business sustainable
this was the importance of having a
business analyst in rob's organization
don't you think every organization
should have a business analyst
well yes depending on the business
domain and the situation the roles and
responsibilities may vary let's now
define the role of a business analyst
a business analyst serves as a conduit
between the customer community and the
software development team through which
requirements flow
business analysts have the primary
responsibility to elicit analyze
validate verify and manage the real
needs of the project stakeholders
including customers and end users
business analysts can play a vital role
in every lifecycle within a project
now let's talk about the
responsibilities of a business analyst
so business analysts should know the
goals and objectives of the business
they must have a good knowledge of the
business operations a business analyst
should understand the problems related
to the business and come up with the
right solution
business analysts often work closely
with the development team to design and
implement the business solution hence
business analysts effectively
collaborate with them and ensure that
they give valuable feedback and monitor
the progress of the work
business analysts assess the functional
and non-functional requirements business
analysts validate if the project is
running fine and also verify the
solution being worked on has all the
requirements incorporated
a business analyst documents the project
findings and results the present the
project conclusions to the stakeholders
and clients using reports and dashboards
to make decisions
with that
let's now look at the top skills a
business analyst should possess
a business analyst should understand the
problems related to the business and
come up with the right solution they
work on individual actions and tasks
that will build towards the achievement
of the goals of the business
a business analyst should be able to
analyze and interpret the client's
requirements clearly
critical thinking involves evaluating
several options before arriving at the
desired solution
this allows the business analyst to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those that
should be given a low priority
the third skill they need to possess is
to have presentation and communication
skills
business analysts use communication and
interpersonal skills when the project is
launched while collecting requirements
and when collaborating with stakeholders
they should be able to document their
project learnings and results in a
concise and compact form they must be
confident about presenting their
findings and conclusions in front of the
stakeholders and clients
another important business analyst skill
is having hands-on experience with
programming languages
business analysts should have a good
understanding of programming for
performing better and faster analysis of
data
having knowledge of r and python is
highly crucial business analysts work
with structured data hence to store and
process this data they should have
knowledge of relational databases such
as microsoft sql server mysql database
as well as nosql databases such as
mongodb they also need to know microsoft
excel to perform various calculations
budget analysis and data analysis to
derive meaningful insights to take
decisions
the final skill a business analyst
should have is data visualization
a business analyst should be expert in
using business intelligence tools such
as tableau power bi and click view for
creating reports and dashboards now with
this understanding
let's now learn the business analysis
knowledge areas
first up we have business analysis
planning and monitoring now this
knowledge area describes the tasks used
to organize and coordinate business
analysis efforts
it involves planning business analysis
approach stakeholder engagement business
analysis governance as well as
information management
then we have illustration and
collaboration
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to prepare and conduct
elicitation activities and confirm the
results
it also includes communicating business
analysis information and stakeholder
engagement
the third knowledge area we have is
requirements lifecycle management
so this knowledge area describes the
tasks that we perform in order to manage
and maintain requirements throughout
their lifecycle
it covers the creation changes
privatization traceability and
governance processes
fourth in our list we have strategy
analysis
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to identify the business need
address that need and align the change
strategy within the enterprise
you need to analyze the current state
define the future state assess risk and
define change strategy
then
we have requirements analysis and design
definition
this knowledge area describes the tasks
used to organize requirements specify
and model requirements it also validates
and verifies information and identifies
solution options the final knowledge
area we have is solution evaluation this
knowledge area measures the solution
performance analyzes performance
measures
assess solution limitations and
recommends actions to increase solution
value now let's discuss two of the most
widely used methodologies in any
business analysis process
these methods are popularly used in the
industries to ensure smooth running of
projects
the first methodology we are going to
talk about is the agile
methodology agile is an incremental and
iterative approach to project management
and software development it helps team
deliver value to their customers faster
and with fewer obstacles
teams can manage a project by breaking
it up into several stages and involving
constant collaboration with stakeholders
along with continuous improvement and
iteration at every stage
so the steps involved in an agile
project development includes
planning the project in terms of
business goals
budget time duration for completing the
project and resource needed
then we have designing the solution for
the problem at hand
the third step is developing the
solution this could be a software a
website an application etc
it's done by the development team
next we have testing the product in the
next step of the life cycle
deploying the developed product to check
if it's working fine and finally we have
reviewing the product and getting
feedback from customers clients
stakeholders etc now in agile
methodology the entire work is broken
down into several sprints
after each sprint we get a shippable
product and that product is reviewed by
the client or the stakeholder the
suggestions are incorporated in the next
sprint
here you can see we have sprint 1 sprint
2 and sprint 3 and all of them have the
6 steps that we discussed in the agile
methodology process
now let's discuss this scrum methodology
scrum is a subset of the agile framework
it is one of the most widely used
lightweight process frameworks for agile
development
you can easily collaborate develop and
deliver complex products of the highest
possible value
scrum empowers the development team and
supports working in small teams like 8
to 10 members
scrum significantly increases
productivity and reduces time
this process enables organizations to
adjust smoothly to rapidly changing
requirements and produce a product that
meets evolving business goals
okay so the concepts and practices in
scrum can be divided into three
categories
first we have three roles
a product owner owns the product backlog
and writes user stories and acceptance
criteria
they are responsible for privatizing the
product backlog and deciding the release
date and the content a product owner is
the one who is responsible for the
return on investment or roi of the
product a scrum master is a servant who
encourages and demands self-organization
from the development team they enable
close cooperation across all roles and
functions addresses resource issues and
disobedience of scrum practices a
development team comprises individuals
working together to develop and deliver
the requested and committed product
agreements the development team builds
the product and includes all the
expertise necessary to deliver the
potential shippable product each sprint
the second category comprises of three
artifacts the product backlog is an
ordered list of the features and
requirements needed to complete the
project the list can include bugs or
defects that need to be resolved
features that must be added another
technical or project work your team has
to complete before the project is over
the sprint backlog includes only what
needs to be completed during the current
sprint
it often has greater detail and more
complete user stories than the rest of
the product backlog
once created no one can add to the
sprint backlog except the development
team the product increment is the
version of the product that will be
delivered at the end of each sprint
while the sprint backlog outlines what
must be completed within a sprint the
product increment details the outcome of
all that work
the increment is a prototype or working
version of the final product expected by
the customer
the final category we have is sprint
ceremonies
there are four ceremonies in total
in sprint planning the team meets and
decides what they need to complete in
the coming sprint
sprint review is a type of meeting in
which the team demonstrates what they
shipped in the sprint
in the sprint retrospective the team
reviews their work identifying what they
did well and what didn't go as planned
so that they can make the next print
better
daily scrum is a stand-up meeting or a
very short like 15 to 20 minutes meeting
for the team to make sure that they are
all on the same page
now
let's talk about the average annual
salary of a business analyst
according to pay scale the average
annual salary of a business analyst in
the united states is 68
973
while in india a business analyst can
earn nearly 6 lakh rupees per annum now
talking about the companies hiring for
business analysts we have the indian
e-commerce payment system and financial
technology company paytm american mnc
cognigent and british dutch
multinational oil and gas company shell
we also have cisco the search engine
giant google and dell
finally in our list of companies we have
einstein young global limited american
multinational computer technology
cooperation oracle and british
multinational investment bank and
financial services company barclays
with that let's discuss the top business
analysis tools and software used by
business analysts
we have the widely used spreadsheet
application microsoft excel
web-based kanban style list making
application trello
relational database management systems
such as mysql microsoft sql server and
postgres sql
then we have bug tracking and agile
project management product zera and
tableau software for data visualization
okay so let's look at a demo on business
analyst training
often times business analysts work on
structured data using excel to prepare
reports and dashboards
they do create pivot tables and pivot
charts to summarize and analyze data
find trends and insights to make
critical decisions
so in this demo we will work on a sales
data set from the united states and
analyze the total revenue total profit
the quantity sold for different
categories and subcategories of products
across various regions segments cities
etc
now let me show you the data set first
okay so here is my data set you can see
there are
nearly
9994 rows and we have
17 columns you can see this is a sales
data set and the first column is of
order date then we have the shipment
date we have the shipment mode next we
have the customer name
that is the customer who purchased the
product we have the segment the country
name this is only united states then we
have the different cities from the u.s
we have the state names
and if i go to the right you can see the
categories of product
we also have the sub categories
next we have the product name
then we have our sales value
now you can assume this to be in dollars
then we have the quantity that was sold
for each product
then we have the discount column and
finally we have the profit column
so let's analyze this data set using
different charts and graphs
first let's create a pivot table to see
the sales by region and year so here we
want to see the sales of all the years
in different regions of the united
states
so for that
i'll click on any cell inside this data
set
go to the insert tab
and here i have the option to create a
pivot table
i'll click on this create pivot table
option
and you can see it has selected my
entire data
and here i'll choose new worksheet that
is the place where i want to place this
pivot table and let's click on
ok so you can see it has created a new
sheet which is sheet2
and
let's drag our columns
onto the different sections in this
pivot table fields
so since i want to know
the region
and the year so let's drag the order
date first
and
let's delete
the quarter column so i'll click on
remove field
i don't want this field so i have my
ears first
and then
let's drag
region column
under columns
and
we want to know the sales for
all the years in different regions so
i'll drag
sales onto values
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready if you want you can go ahead and
rename this row labels and column labels
now
with this table ready let's create a
line chart
this will help you analyze your data
better
so what you can do is
go to the insert tab and here
under recommended charts
you can go for line chart you can see
the line chart preview here and click on
ok
there you go
how easily excel has created
a pivot chart for us based on
this pivot table
now if you notice the lines in this
graph you can see the different regions
and here is the legend
now
if you see the yellow line which is
actually for the west region
so the sales had declined from 2014
to 2015
and then it gradually started increasing
from 2015 to 2017 onwards
and if you see the orange line or the
red line it is for the east region
the sales have been continuously
increasing you can see the trend here
similarly
if you see the central region
the sales generated was steady from 2014
to 2015
then it increased in 2016 and after 2016
it became constant
similarly you can analyze the south
region as well
now let's say you want to know the sales
by each category of product and the
different segments so you can do that as
well
let's go to our sheet one where we have
our data set
let me click on any cell i'll go to
insert
and i'll choose pivot table
here
let it be new worksheet i'll click on ok
all right so since we want to know the
sales value again so let's drag sales
onto
values field
and now
i'll choose
category
under rows so
let's select category under rows
and then
we want to know
for each segment also
so what i can do is
i'll choose segment under columns
you can see i have my pivot table ready
so here you have
the furniture office supplies and
technology as the categories of products
and on the top you can see consumer
corporate home office as the different
segments
now let's create a
visual out of this pivot table so i'll
go to recommended charts
and
let's say this time i want to
create a bar chart now this is a
horizontal bar chart
let's click on ok
if i close this
and i bring it to here you can see this
is a nice bar chart
and below you can see the sales values
and on the y-axis you can see the
different categories of products and in
the legend we have the segments
now if you want you can edit this chart
as well
so let's delete
or hide all field buttons on the chart
all right
similarly let's do this for
our line chart as well let's hide these
field buttons okay
all right
now
let's suppose you want to know which
segment made the highest and the lowest
profits
so for that you can create a pivot table
as well
so i'll click on any cell
go to the insert tab
and choose pivot table i click on ok
all right
now say
we want to know the profit by each
segment
so i'll first choose profit on to values
and
let's drag
the segment column
onto rows
so we have our pivot table ready
now here if you want to know which
segment made the highest or the lowest
profit you can sort this data so click
on any cell under sum of profit
right click and here you have the short
option
so let's do
sort smallest to largest which is in
ascending order
okay so here you can see consumer
segment made the highest amount of
profit while the home office segment
made the lowest amount of profit now
based on this pivot table you can create
a pie chart
let's do that
i'll go to insert
and here under recommended charts
i'll select
pi
and let's click on ok
there you go
we have a nice pie chart ready
now the gray color pi represents your
consumer segment which made the highest
amount of profit you can also validate
it from the pivot table while the blue
segment which is actually home office
made the lowest amount of profit
now let's remove this field from here
i'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart
now one thing you can do is
you can edit the
chart title
here by default it has shown total we
can rename it to let's say
profit
by
segment
and hit enter
okay
now you can adjust the size of this and
the color of the text if you want you
can do it from here
similarly
let's
add a title to our bar graph as well
so here if you see
there is an option to choose chart title
and
i'll say sales
by
segment
and
category
okay
similarly let's add a title to
our first line chart that we created
i'll click on the chat title and here
i'll
write sales by
year
and
region
okay
now let me go back to my
data sheet now suppose let's say you
want to know
the total units that were sold for each
sub category of products and the
shipment mode
so here we have the shipment mode
and you want to know the total units
that were sold which is basically
this column the quantity column
for each sub categories of product you
can see we have different sub categories
like bookcases this chairs labels the
stables furnacings art phones binders
etc
so let's create a pivot table for this
i'll go to the insert tab
click on pivot table
and click on ok
all right
now
since we want to know the total units
that were sold let's drag
the quantity column under values
and
i'll choose
the ship mode field under columns
and let's select
sub category
under rows
so i have my pivot table ready
now based on this pivot table let's
create a line chart i'll go to the
insert tab
click on recommended charts
and let's go to line chart
all right
you can see the preview here and the
legends which show the
shipment mode let's click on ok
i close this now
first let's remove these fields i'll
right click and i'll hide all field
buttons
now if you see this one
you can
add some styles to your chart
let's modify our chart a bit
let's see i'll select
yeah this one
you can see
it has given dots for each end points
which means
this is my first sub category as you can
see the second sub category the third
sub category which is art
then we have binders
so it's really easy to read
and understand the chart well
okay
now
let's add a chart title
i'll write
quantity
sold
by
subcategory
and
ship mode
now you can reduce the size of the
chart title text let's keep it
10
okay
now you
also have the
feature to create
different kinds of maps in excel
so suppose
you want to see the states that made the
highest and the lowest sales in the
united states so you can create a field
map for that
so first of all let's go to our data
sheet
i'll click on any cell go to insert and
create a pivot table
and click on ok
all right
so since we want the
state and the country so let me first
drag country field under rows
and then i'll choose the state field
under rows
now let's
drag sales under values
okay
so we have our
pivot table ready now if i sort this
data you can easily know
that california state made the highest
amount of sales
now if i scroll down
below you can see
north dakota made the lowest amount of
sales
now
let's do one thing let's remove the
grand total so you can go to the design
tab
and
under grand totals you can select the
first option you can see the grand total
has gone
and in order to create a map we need to
adjust this pivot table so i'll click on
united states
i'll right click
and
i'll go to field settings
here under
layout and print
i'll click on
show item labels in tabular format
and i'll also click on repeat item
labels you can see
it will populate united states for all
the rows if i click on ok you can see
the united states have been populated
for all the states
now let
me select this table
or before that let's remove the
subtotal from here
i'll close this
go to the design tab
under
subtotals i'll choose do not show
subtotals okay
now let's
select the table
and
i'll actually paste it somewhere here
now with this data
i can go to the insert tab
and choose maps
let's select field map
there you go
you see
we have a nice field map of the united
states
and here you can see the color scale
so it goes from light gray all the way
up to dark blue
so the states that are
in dark blue
let's say california made the highest
amount of sales you can also validate it
from the pivot table
similarly the lighter the color
the amount of sales were less for that
state
now let's give a chart title here
i'll
give a chart title
as
sales by
states
and let's remove this legend
now you can format this map so here you
can change colors and
let's see if i chose this one you can
see the color has changed
and you can see the california state
is shaded in dark which means it made
the highest amount of sales
you can also
add data labels you can see it will show
the
sales values for each of the states
and if you want you can keep the legend
as well i'll just remove these two
all right
now
similarly you can also create a field
map
to see the profits by each state so you
can analyze which states made the
highest amount of profit and the state
that made the lowest amount of profit
so let's do that
i'll go to my data sheet
i'll
click on insert and select pivot table
let's click on ok
now first and foremost
let's drag country under rows
and then i'll choose state under rows
next
let's drag
the profit column under values
so i have my
pivot table ready
let's go to the design tab and remove
the subtotals
i'll select do not show subtotals if i
scroll down
okay i have my grand total now so let's
go to the design tab under grand totals
we'll remove it
okay
now let's just populate the united
states which is the country name for all
the rows
i'll right click on united states go to
field settings
click on layout and print
i'll choose
select item labels in tabular form and
select repeat item labels
let's click on ok
so i have my country name populated
throughout
let's
select the pivot table
i'll paste it somewhere here
and now let's go to the insert tab
i'll choose
map let's select field map
there you go
now we have the
profits
for each of the states
let's first delete this
and edit our chart title
which is
profit
by
states
okay
let's close this
let's say
we'll use this one now
okay
let's edit the color of the chart title
i'll make it as white
and let's say
we'll
choose the color
say this one
okay
now let me go ahead and remove the
legend here
and just delete it
all right
so we have our
field map ready which shows profit by
each state
now that we are done with our analysis
and creating our
different pivot tables and pivot charts
let's build the final dashboard
so let's create a new sheet here
okay
the first thing i need to do is i'll go
to the view tab and i'll remove the grid
lines
all right now let's go to the insert tab
and here we have
text
let me choose text box
let's create a text box here
okay
now you can reduce the size actually
let's reduce it
okay
and you can move it to the top
all right
let's pull this a little down
and this too little right
let's fill the text box color with
blue color
and
let's
give the text as
sales
dashboard
and we'll
give a white color to the text
and i'll select my font
you can select any font you want
so i'll go with
let's say
britannic bold
okay we have it here
and
let's increase the size to
30
and we'll center align it all right
now
the next step is to
bring all our pivot charts
to this dashboard sheet
so i'll first copy my
pivot chart
and i'll paste it in sheet 8 let's paste
it
here and we can reduce the size
okay
now similarly let's do it for the
other charts as well i'll copy this
and let's paste it somewhere here
okay
now let me just reduce the
size
and if you want you can reduce the
chart title font size as well let's make
it 11
okay and let's
drag this a bit
all right
now let's
copy the
pie chart
and let me paste it here let's reduce
the size of this pie chart
okay
see we have our pie chart here
now
let me
take my line chart which shows the
quantity sold by
different sub categories of product i'll
copy it and let me paste it
somewhere here
i'll close this
and we need to reduce the size so that
we can fit in our
other charts as well
okay let me reduce a bit more
all right
now we are left with the two
maps that we created let's copy this
and
let's paste it here
i'll go to the right
let's reduce the size
similarly we'll do it for
sales by
profit map as well
let's copy this
and
paste it
onto our dashboard
let's reduce the size first
and let's increase it
towards the bottom
so we have our dashboard ready you can
see the different
pivot charts that we created
now let's add slicers and timelines to
this dashboard so that we can filter our
tables and the charts
so i'll
click on this
first chart which is our line chart i'll
go to the insert tab here you can see
under filters we have slicers and
timeline
first let me click on timeline and here
i'll choose my order date column
let me click on ok
all right let's drag this a bit here on
to the right
and i'll show you how you can use this
let's
first choose
years instead of months
and let me reduce the size a bit
okay
now another thing to do here is let me
right click
and i'll go to
report connections
here i'll select
all my pivot tables instead of just one
so that
any manipulation you do
in the order year it will reflect for
all the
tables or the charts we have on the
dashboard i click on ok
now that we have seen how to add a
timeline
i'll reduce this a bit
let's now add a few slicers
let's click on any of the charts
i'll go to insert
click on slicer
now let's add
a region slicer i'll click on ok
and let's take it to the right
we'll reduce the size of this region
slicer slicers are nothing but
filters which have
advanced filtering options
and
we can add
one more
filter
or a slicer let's say
we want to do this time on
the segment so i'll go to slicer
i'll choose segment here and click on ok
so you can see i have my segment slicer
here
let me just reduce the size
and let's drag it
here
at the bottom
all right
okay
now if you want to know the sales and
profit
for a particular year so you can choose
that particular year here on the
timeline
suppose i want to know
the sales only for 2014 and 2015.
so the way to do is
you can select one of the years so i'll
click on 2014
and now i'll drag this
to select 2015 as well
if i
go to left
the figures that you see only reflect
the sales and the profit for 2014 and
15.
similarly
if you mark here
or let me just bring it
to the middle
suppose say i want to
have 2016 year included as well i can
just drag it to the right
you can see the charts will change
i'll just
remove the filter and place it here
similarly if you want to
see the sales and profit for
a particular region
you can do that too
for example let me just bring this
region slicer here
and
let's say you want to know the sales and
profit only for the east region
you see here it shows only for the east
region
and suppose you want to see for east and
west region also
you can see it changes here
okay
we just cancel this
now
you might be wondering when we selected
the different regions only the pie chart
changed
but the rest of the charts were
the same now the reason was we did not
apply this slicer to all the pivot
tables so let me right click
and go to report connections
here i'll choose
the remaining pivot tables as well
click on ok
all right
now let me just bring this to the middle
and let's say we want to know the
sales and the profits
and the quantity sold for let's say
south region
if i select this you can see it shows
only for the south region
let's see you also want to know for the
central region
now we have selected both central and
south you can see the variations in the
graph
we cancel this
similarly we have another slicer which
is the segment
i'll populate the slicer for
all the other pivot tables
let me choose all of them
and click on ok
i'll bring this
to the middle so that you can see the
variations in the graph let's say i want
to know the seals the units sold and the
profit for
home office segment so i'll only select
home office
you can see the variations here
now the slicers actually don't work for
the maps so you can't see any change
here
now suppose you want to
know for the corporate segment you can
select cooperate or if you want to
select for multiple segments you can do
that as well
just cancel this
and let me place it here
all right now we are done with our demo
so if you want to get a copy of the data
set and the demo file that we are using
here in this video you can put your
email ids in the comment section
our team will send you the files over
email
and that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on business analyst
training
you learnt a lot of concepts related to
business analysis and also performed a
demo using excel i hope it was
interesting if you liked it then please
subscribe to the simply learn channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update thank you for watching and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here